- This then led to a drinking contest.
- What?
- Last man standing is the winner.
- Challenge accepted.
- (Harold) Which in turn
led to a limerick contest.
- Limericks?
- Yes mam.
Some of them, I'm afraid to say
are a little off color.
- Well go on then.
- All right,
the first one went a little like
There was a young woman from Delaware
- Who liked to make
love, liked to make love
- Delaware
- In her underwear.
- [Princess Margaret] A terrible prude
- She would never go nude
and her bum, hips and tits
she would never bare.
(laughter)
- What else?
- The president countered with;
there was a young man from Wisconsin,
who was blessed with an enormously large
- Johnson
(laughter)
- Where's the rest of it?
- I believe everyone thought
that was long enough.
As it were.
- Any more?
- Princess Margret won
the evening with this one,
there was a young lady from Dallas,
who used a dynamite stick as a phallus,
- They found her
- You've made it this far.
- They found her vagina in North Carolina,
- And her arsehole in Buckingham Palace.
(laughter)
- Bravo